- So last time we talked
about surfing in Malibu.
So were you there when
the fires got crazy?
- Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I was working.
And I watched on the news as the fire
was barreling down the PCH
and it was headed straight
for them little tiny
community where I live.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And because of the bravery of 10 men
who stayed and fought the fire,
a couple of ex firefighters
and some lifeguards,
they saved our community
but my community was completely cut off.
They had one FEMA meal a day
but they were running out of
gasoline for the generators
'cause there was no power.
They were running out of eye wash,
chocolate, booze, everything.
(Kelly laughing)
- All the key things.
- All of the vital components
for survival. Exactly.
- So yeah.(Kelly chuckles)
- So I was like, "Okay."
I'd just gone through a terrible breakup
and was maybe not in
the best frame of mind
but I was like, "I need to deliver goods."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- However, the only way you
could get in was by boat
and because people had started looting
the coast guard had issued
a zero ship to shore.
So you'd be arrested
if you tried to get in.
Nonetheless, I found
a boat and the captain
and I just had to figure out
how I was gonna get
the stuff from the boat
into the beach and I needed some help.
- You became a good pirate.
- [Minnie] I did.
- I like it.
- I was like,
"Who can I get to go do this with me?"
So I remember this dude that I'd met
at a friend's breakfast.
And he was just this really
intrepid Indiana Jones type.
- Perfect guy.
- Explorer. Called him up.
I was like, "Will you help me
launch a sea-based incursion?
You might get arrested."
- A sea-based incursion?
- There was a big silence.
And then he was like, "Yeah, I'll do it."
And we did it.
We got chased by the coast guard.
We got, there was a
mounted gun on that boat.
We had the gasoline balanced
on the paddle boards.
We were paddling it in.
We dragged it on the beach.
We ran away.
The coast guard hung out
all day waiting for us to come back.
We were shipwrecked in my
house that had no electricity,
no water, nothing.
And he basically,
I asked him every question
about why men unfaithful,
why men do the things that they do.
I was like, "You are trapped.
I'm really sorry.
I wanna ask you a lot of questions."
And he was kind of
like, "Well, all right."
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And so we hung out the whole day.
I got to know him.
We made it back to the
Marina del Ray at midnight,
we're standing on the thing.
I was like, "I'm ruined.
I'm never gonna have another boyfriend."
And he was like, "Well,
I don't want a girlfriend
and definitely not you."
(audience laughing)
But we stood there.
And then of course we became friends,
and of course we fell in love.
And of course we've been
together ever since.
- [Kelly] This is a movie.
(audience clapping)
- [Minnie] Yeah.
- Wait, what?
That's how it ended?
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- He's the greatest person I ever met
apart from my son and my mother.
- Wait, when are you making this movie?
- [Minnie] I gotta make it into a movie.
I gotta make it into a movie.
- You gotta make it into a movie.
- If only I knew some people.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- God. Dang it.